- Thank you so much for
being a part of our,
We love New York week.
We love.
- I am so glad to be here.
You guys are back in New York.
I was like yes.
- I'm excited,
we're excited.
Do you remember
the first time you came to the city?
Is there like a clear
memory you have of that?
- Girl?
Yes.
Okay, when I was a teen,
it's when my group Escape.
We were first doing our thing.
And every time I came for
the first three times,
I saw a bike rider on the ground,
laid out because they were hit by a taxi.
- What?
- Every trip,
it was somebody laid out.
- Is this like a common thing?
- It must be common
because my makeup artist,
he just was in accident
where he was on his bike and got hit
by a car.
- What?
- I said oh my God.
You guys are still doing this?
- Oh my gosh.
- Yes.
- Like open your eyes.
Do you have a favorite spot here though?
That you would tell me like
to eat or anything to go?
- I think one
of my favorite places is,
when we were doing well when
I was a part of Chicago,
I was Mama Morton.
I used to love going
to Serafina across the street and eat.
I love Italian food.
- I just.
This is not a joke.
I just had Sarafina last night.
- Really?
- Somebody was like,
what do you want to eat?
And we had to like Postmate it I think,
'cause we were working so much
and so we Postmated at
Serafina and was so good.
- I love it.
Their food is really good.
I go there.
- I had some kind of truffle pasta.
It was mem mem mem,
it was so good.
Yeah it was really good.